how's it going
my name is Pierre Dubois welcome back to
happy wheels as its pleasure to play
these are all super difficult I try them
before out like how do you do that
I don't understand let's do downhill
that sounds pretty epic all right son
we are finally here to go skiing yeah
but Dad I want to go skiing with skis I
don't care we used to bicycle in this
family but Dad I'm scared oh that did
not go as planned
okay this annoying I'm sorry that's not
the matter I doubt I'll make it north
pole rush car thief the combine did we
play the combine
what I said this oh snap oh no no that
did not go as planned
let's try that again the combine all
right yeah yeah front flip how's a bad
idea let's not run too late all right oh
man watch going on here alright front
flip yeah yeah oh no I lost my arm it's
okay can I cut people is this a grass
cutter I'm gonna cut that fracking hobo
gimme that [ __ ] Oh Oh my head got stuck
Oh bro what did they do to you that got
hurt that got hurt a lot obstacle course
well that sounds delighting dad I'm
tired I just want to go home I don't
want to go home to mom
I don't care we're going to finish this
obstacle cars and if it's the last thing
I'll ever do but there are spikes which
I'll finish based on the wrath ah be
quiet you don't know anything
oh snap oh crap Oh doh
son are you all right son I whatever
that puss yes I just climbed these like
a bus get some speed yeah
we made it son yeah yeah yeah I want to
hear some excitement yeah
you call that excitement son oh you are
just one big disappointment aren't you
what is this freaking flying axis I
don't care yeah
the extremes you care for that well that
could have been good if I saw it before
I don't know dad I feel scared all right
so far so good why are you complaining
holy [ __ ] shut up yes yes we made it dad
it's an arrow and you took it to the
knee and now that makes me disappointed
you know I disappoint us just one big
letdown I don't care my finally finally
some quiet good you're almost there
finally no no no hey guys all right a
minute without that [ __ ] yes son just
one big letdown that son all right
cannon town that sounds delightful
all right I have a segue [ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah yeah just pump that [ __ ] pump
that [ __ ]
Oh Oh feels so good feels alright I got
it okay I have to eject I think eject
with Zeb and other actions with control
and yeah sayonara [ __ ] no no no ha ha
ha I'm not gonna give up I'm not gonna
never gonna give you up never gonna let
you down never gonna run around and hurt
you never gonna make you cry gotta go in
this freakin cannon gonna get shy about
I don't care no yeah yeah I gotta grab
this I gotta grab this [ __ ]
grab that yes head first [ __ ]
oh no so close buddy I do apologize
about your head all right I saw some
really cool before I recorded but I
didn't have my microphone working it was
called Viking yeah there it is Viking
revenge let's do it all right we got a
dodge in there dodge dodge Thor's hammer
I don't even care
did you bros know that the guy who owns
the what the hell this happened trees
killed me apparently the guy who owns
says the seg wheel company actually died
on a Segway I don't know I thought that
was pretty hilarious that guy is like
sub it's a pretty pie big time yeah yeah
I found that [ __ ] oh no oh you think
that's gonna stop me I can still move
you think there's something I don't have
any odds I don't care well he's a real
Viking alright alright come on buddy
just jump that [ __ ] go through the
forest say hello to that woman with a
big that today sorry she's just all
right I assume is Teddy's oh oh let's go
into that oh yeah yeah s'up [ __ ]
bring it i got protection haha you got
you can do [ __ ] bro
pump that [ __ ] pump it all night long
yeah yeah you have a problem with me I
don't care Vikings are [ __ ] ah supple
lady how you doing I'll see you later
all right what do we got here this is no
problem for a man who on a Segway
come okay maybe this all right here we
go
subtree how you doing all right fine I
have one leg but I made this [ __ ] I'm
off in my Viking boat well I was awesome
I never actually finished it well either
run human run get away you [ __ ] what is
this
alright let's eject I suppose let's go
oh no that guy's trying to give me a
[ __ ] stop trying to give me a [ __ ]
I don't appreciate oh snap grab that
[ __ ] no I lost no I totally blow up the
hell was that
alright let's do a couple more because I
know you haven't really canon town we
already played by Atari let's play lost
laboratories so let's do it
Santa Claus run you dirty prescence run
faster you stupid else you call it's
fast this is what I call Oh
oh nice one is still alive oh snap
that Shing is chasing us I don't know
this is not as bland can right no Santa
you died I didn't know it is let's go
Ronnie daddy pageants don't you want to
live I show you the spirit of Christmas
fly you dirty lessons fly there isn't it
the well I mean ah who cares
alright let's go in there no I tell
you're dying watch me
[ __ ] that alright let's do one more with
the psycho dad see Bruce seems to like
him
mound mayhem alright
no I don't wanna play that [ __ ] [ __ ]
on the Segway uh balcony terror obstacle
course the hotel DC metro station sounds
pretty sweet
yes and I said we're on a trip to the
subway station you better behave I'm
sick of your [ __ ] and you're complaining
dad supposed to be in school right now I
don't care about school and stupid [ __ ]
like that
we are gorgeous
don't question my logic we're using the
bicycle it's obvious okay dad whatever
you say [ __ ] shut up that's not you
you're in a gay as opposed to I hope
you're happy
all right we're in the subway now are
you happy like it it's the first time
you actually take me somewhere uh you're
just full of [ __ ] aren't you just trying
to make me look bad in front of my dad I
think you can't someone I don't care he
was fat in fact I know it's a [ __ ]
disgrace come on dad I think we should
go the police might come shut up I'm not
afraid of the police we [ __ ] made it
look look at you on that stupid poster
it shows how gay you are look at that
[ __ ] you're just one [ __ ] gay homo
ass son you're a big [ __ ] you just
big [ __ ] left out I hate me they said
I would make money I am the one who pays
for it just because I did I'd advertise
I don't care shot okay I think I took it
too far anyway the reason why I uploaded
happy wheels because I'm gonna do
subtitles for the amnesia episode it's
in Swedish so it's that's gonna take my
while so I want to topple over something
in the meanwhile I was probably gonna
take like two and a half hours something
like that anyway thank you both so much
for everyone who voted so far in king of
the web we're actually catching up we're
catching up on first place so if you
want to if you haven't heard over there
haven't voted yet please do so link in
description and yeah like favors you
know the episodes have Cairo today and
anyway yes
[Music]
follow me hey Alex